let us now consider an application of
what we have done so far let x be a
normal random variable with given mean
and variance this means that the PDF of
X takes the familiar form we consider a
random variable Y which is a linear
function of X and to avoid trivialities
we assume that a is different than 0 we
will just use the formula that we have
already developed so we have that the
density of Y is equal to 1 over the
absolute value of a and then we have the
density of X but evaluated at X equal to
this expression so this expression will
go in the place of X in this formula and
we have Y minus B over a minus mu
squared divided by 2 Sigma squared and
now we collect these constant terms here
and then in the exponent we multiply by
a squared the numerator and the
denominator which gives us this form
here
we recognize that this is again a normal
PDF it's a function of Y we have a
random variable Y this is the mean of
the normal and this is the variance of
that normal so the conclusion is that
the random variable Y is normal with
mean equal to B plus mu and with
variance a squared Sigma squared the
fact that this is the mean and this is
the variance of Y is not surprising this
is how means and variances behave when
you form linear functions the
interesting part is that the random
variable Y is actually normal
intuitively what happened here is that
we started with a normal bell shaped
curve a bell shaped PDF 4x we scale it
vertically and horizontally and then
shift it horizontally by B as we do
these operations the PDF still remains
bell-shaped and so the final PDF is
again a bell shaped normal PDF